you
throw those opening books out opening
books aren't gonna be too helpful are
they this is Fisher random and white
usually has an advantage on chest cubed
time wise notice his clock isn't ticking
but as soon as he makes a move guess
whose clock starts moving and I have to
come up with something
so what's unprotected nothing
everything's protected from this
arrangement I like this is a first move
as well or this but I prefer hang on
yeah I like this too I like giving my
queen some breathing space and I like
bringing my knight out behind the pond
so this is the symmetrical variation of
some Fisher phantoms that but here's one
thing that I've noticed from my
experience with this variant of chests
Fisher random these bishops don't have
to move to be developed just the pawns
in front of them
they're not in anyone anyone's way if I
wanted a Castle kingside I'd have to
move him and these two to Castle
queenside they only need to move my
queen and then drop my king of my rook
and the rook ends up here my King ends
up here so I think I might want to do
this move also or this he's I mean he's
gonna do this I don't know
we're gonna end up with a a court grip
in the center that term was used in a
book called pond power by hon Squatch
quark grip where there's a pond here
here and this the ponds here they
control all four center squares and so
far we're well this pond is now hit and
what's my last move I'm hitting here I
think I just want to defend so that's
why I was saying we're probably going to
end up having quark grips so I need to
activate my bishop and my knight
probably here if I'm if I'm gonna be
playing here with my pawn I need to be
very cautious of this square Knight or
Bishop could jump in this one might be a
move but then again it concedes the d4
square we both have to be very cautious
here we don't want to really get leave
any gaps with our moves
and right now I'm threatening to just
win this pawn so I wonder if he'll do
similar you'll notice I went with this
pawn because moving this one is much
more committal weakening this diagonal
that the bishop is clearly already on so
we once again have a perfectly
symmetrical position after these five
moves everything is the same where will
it change it'll change usually after our
capture and things are gonna be
different for sure
so how will things go from here I'm
considering Knight d7 to f6 I'm not sure
what I want to do with my epon if I'm to
move my Queen I'd probably be wanting to
go here should I still just kind of copy
let's copy one more why not it seems
like a good move I'm not just doing it
to copy I'm being uh I think it's
sensible I think he's making sensible
moves and I I think that this is the
right spot for the night
this is slowly evolving into a position
where our nights are developed
classically and I don't want to so this
is where things are now going to change
so I don't want to trade he looks like
he's a stupid piece now but and maybe he
is maybe he is but okay now I have this
court grip these four pawns control all
four Center squares Queen here Bishop
here and then I could Castle kingside
I'm not sure what I want to do with my
King just yet I think a very important
idea in Fischer random is to mask your
Kings location keep keep his residence a
bit of a disguise stay flexible so okay
we do have some action in the center and
well what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do about that you know I don't
really have to fear I don't really have
to fear pawn push because I believe I'd
end up winning it let me let me get my
Queen developed I think this is best if
pawn takes I'm pretty sure taking like
this is best however you know I don't
know come to think of it that's not sure
about that
if pawn takes pawn takes like this I'm
weakening this square but then again I
have coverage all right I have pieces
that are responsible for watching over
this square now this starts to become a
bit of an issue because this move that I
thought couldn't be played is maybe
close to being played I think white is
ready to undermine this pawn by playing
e5 and maybe still could have done that
on the previous move I didn't really
consider that I thought here takes takes
Knight here I'm hitting it three times
and I was forgetting that c5 would be
unprotected
he's also watching over d4 from a night
jump I wonder if I should take and then
play here takes takes pawn push
I'm gonna try that after I have to fire
off some will we're pretty much debt
equal with the time let's see how white
recaptures structurally this would be
better I think cuz now he's a little bit
awkward and I think I want to take like
this just so my bishop could see the
world and as a follow-up I think I want
to have some type of a grip over this
square it's not gonna be so easy though
no no no no no I think I just calmly
bump up here and now I'm ready to Castle
kingside I think should be pretty safe
and then I might want to just open the
position up there might be some
sacrifice here but I don't think that
and I think white is in a position to
really open up the position because I
actually have a slight lead in
development and I'm gonna zip my king
over here so in case anything crazy
happens on this square my king is not
gonna be in any danger so he's down to
50 seconds and I'm considering b6 and
then here maybe maybe there's something
more direct can I open stuff up right
away maybe I could give this knight a
kick yeah let me do that I'm gonna kick
him around
you can't Kat you could Castle queenside
but that's very scary isn't it I have
one Bishop bearing right down that's
this is scary now he has to go to the
corner and now this pawn is gonna be a
monster
he can't move or capture because he's
unprotected less than 30 and now because
of this advance my rook is brought right
to life my knight also has a good home
since the pond could never advance to a3
so this is this is a really devastating
pawn advance and now this is dropping
material I think I do well to first just
take make sure the file is opened up
this comes with check and if after this
recapture now this pawn is pinned I'm
not really
a big fan of capturing pink pieces but
in this case I think that it's it's it's
just the best move because it's
activating my queen
and what other piece am i needing to
activate this Bishop this rook still
need to do something I can bring my
queen oh I'd like to get my bishop on
this diagonal they always have some
block here let's hope let's actually
open up the B file that's the way to
know my goodness let's do this I would
have dropped my rook these Knights
offset one another this is gonna be game
over just clockwise it's just not
happening its position wise too but that
was that only really shifted advantage
really only went one way or the other as
soon as there was a problem time was all
right good game let's go let's go back
here and flip the board so we kind of
copied here and I pretty much shared
everything I wanted to share during the
game didn't have to move the bishops in
order to have them have an impact on the
position just the pawns in front of them
we both did that we both copied one
another we both with our first move got
our ponds up in front of our queen so
she had some room to breathe and our
Knights like to be right behind those
pawns
they're jumping points are already
supported by the pond that's a good
thing and this is where things deviated
so white induced a weakness and then
dropped back this is a I don't know how
much better developed it is I don't know
what was really accomplished maybe
there's some way to improve at that
point in the game but really just came
down to what maybe this was the last
very important point in the game there's
this pawn captures the one to be
perfectly honest this is the one that
worried meanwhile was
if you take with the pond I'm really
concerned about 'if I've undermining
this this link of ponds just these two
ponds alone this small structure C 5 and
D 6 I'd be really concerned about you
push pushing forward grabbing some space
and I think after this capture I'm
having to play here and it's a whole new
world it's a whole new position because
then you could immediately jump into d5
and well I think it I think it turns out
to be a more difficult position more a
more tense position more critical for me
well then again I mean if you get if i
play this 'if i've move i weakened d5
but then again this d4 square is already
we could consider that already a hole so
I just don't know I I started to feel
comfortable at this point right here
when I knew I didn't have to deal with
any other pond all right as soon as I
didn't have to deal with the white pawn
on e4 so now I've as soon as I didn't
have to worry about a 5 I felt a little
bit comfortable I was able to make that
bishop move and then get castled but I
think this was the really the main the
the last critical point in the game
night here I think is fine maybe even
here maybe instead of the knight move
maybe you could do this because of this
pressure no no you have to be careful
too I'm seeing something now you know
one thing that I wasn't seeing all the
while is that after after this capture
the Queen has pressure here so doing
doing that move at this point right here
when the night is still on d2 if you do
this after captures the Queen's ready to
take care and have that be with check
however after the night is on b3 now
this is a threat
so that if I take you're able to take on
c5 with the knight attack my queen and
defend the pawn on d3 but this I think
again the last critical point in the
game how exactly to recapture on e4 it's
not so easy to really come up with that
in this short and this fast type of game
but yeah I think it started this slip
right now I think your best bet is to go
King side but uh we're pretty low on
time at that point it just kind of
crumbles as soon as this file opens up
and where castle down opposite side so I
think I'm better positioned to attack
your King
alrighty good game I think that was the
first time at least in 960 that how
we've played alrighty
you